thanks to you thanks to all of you for
coming as you said to
bringing data science workflows to the
web and to the browser in particular so
really briefly what we'll be talking
about is I'll show you ayuh died which
is an experimental tool we've been
building to bring these familiar
interactive and iterative data science
workflows that you all know from things
like Ian's talking in Jupiter lab to the
web we'll be talking about Piatt died
which brings Python into the browser
I'll briefly talk about the iodide
server which kind of ties this together
and then we'll have time for questions
so iodide is a tool for bringing data
science communications workflows into
the browser so there are a couple
different kinds of data science
workflows that you guys are probably
familiar with there's code focused
workflows so those are going to be
things where the the thing that you're
trying to produce is really code the
artifact at the end of the day is
production software so a workflow like
that might be something like producing a
machine learning algorithm to optimize
click-throughs or something like that
the workflows have this critical
exploratory phase where you're going to
be using tools like our studio or
Jupiter to explore your data to produce
plots to try out different models and at
the end of the day you might switch to
something like vs code to kind of
productionize your code another workflow
is a communication focused workflow so
in that case the the thing you're
producing is something more like a
document and in this case the focus
really is communication so this will be
like doing exploratory data analysis
where you're looking through a stack of
data to try to come up with some kind of
pattern that might influence a decision
again these workflows have this
exploratory phase where you're going to
be using tools like Jupiter or our
studio and then hopefully at the end of
the day you can either pass off a
notebook or maybe a similar like like
our markdown document to your
collaborators but sometimes you might
just switch to a PDF or you might have
to switch to a more traditional document
of some kind and today like I said we're
going to be talking about this
communication focused workflow so there
are these these great researchers down
out of the the UCSD design lab we've
actually been doing a lot of really
interesting user research on
computational notebooks and they they
had this paper that was kind of making
the rounds a few months ago called
exploration and exploration in
computational notebooks they analyzed
I think 1.2
jupiter notebooks something in that
range and they did a lot of user
research and interviews with with users
of jupiter and similar technologies and
they found that workflows often had
these two critical phases this
exploration phase and then this
explanation phase we also have found in
our work at mozilla that there's this
collaboration phase that we need to to
bring into this loop and ideally all of
this would happen in in a tool like
jupiter or our markdown where you'll do
your exploration in your notebook you'll
hand that off to the decision-makers or
their collaborators to to look at that
explanation they can immediately take
that notebook start hacking on it re
mixing it and join in that collaboration
and that cycle will continue in practice
this is sometimes a little more
complicated or a little more involved
the exploration really in my experience
in our experience at mozilla jupiter is
a is the best tool for that by far
things like jupiter in our studio again
for the explanation phase we often find
that in our workflows like our product
managers our executives often have
trouble dealing with this combination of
code and explanation and that that
mixture and so oftentimes what we'll end
up doing is copying kind of like our key
plots data tables analyses summary
statistics that kind of stuff
back out to a Google Doc or a PDF or
something like that and then maybe at
the top of that doc will leave a link
back to the code so for people who are
interested they can go and take a look
at that notebook and remix it and adapt
it to their needs and this experience is
not at all video sync radix so if you
guys have encountered this before you're
not alone
this is what these these researchers
again found a lot of people are doing is
people will do their exploration phase
in a jupiter notebook but when it comes
time for explanation they'll extract
those key figures and those key data
points and put them into another more
traditional document format so that's
one part of a communication workflow
another thing that I want to mention
really briefly here is interactive
database so in modern communication
workflows interactive data vis is really
important and buys us a lot right and so
we're all familiar with things like this
538 interactive database which is going
to be in d3 and
these nice kind of like things where you
can hover over the plots and it will
drill them and give you a little bit
more insight into what's going on or you
can really dive down into the various
features of a map or whatever else it is
what's great about this kind of
interactive data visualization is it
allows you to get the high level
overview while at the same time drilling
down into the details of the data that
you're interested in and that kind of
thing is hard if you're working with a
static artifact so if you're copying
figures to a Google Doc you can't really
do that kind of that kind of interactive
visualization because you need
computation to be close to presentation
for this kind of thing to work right
whenever you're hovering over one of
those elements of that map a little bit
of code is being run that's altering the
UI on the fly so we just saw in Adams
talk the the Lorenz attractor demo let
me bring that up unfortunately in my
this binder I don't know why it's not
working now but interact isn't working
here anymore in any case we just saw it
for those of you here for Adams talk you
just saw that the joopa demo um you can
see in this screenshot here Jupiter does
allow some of this this nice
interactivity and it's getting better
and better as we just saw like it's it's
improving by leaps and bounds what that
demo is going to show is they're these
little sliders and if you pull them back
and forth it actually updates the
parameters of the Lorenz attractor so
you can kind of dig in and explore a
little bit with some of that
interactivity what that what that model
looks like so what I want to show you
now is how that would look in iodide so
again iodide is this experimental tool
that we're building at Mozilla to try to
bring some of the tools that we're
familiar with as data scientists to the
web so here's what a similar explanation
would look like in a in a an iodide
notebook and the first thing you should
notice is that it doesn't look like a
notebook at all it looks like a web page
with a write-up so
it's just it's a it's like standard text
and you have this graphic that you can
hover and zoom and scroll around on and
it's all the computations happening in
the browser next to the presentation so
you've got all the advantages of WebGL
for motion 3d all this kind of stuff
you also can hover over it and as you
adjust the parameters of the the
presentation that all updates in real
time so we're not sending a signal out
to a kernel which is rendering a PNG and
sending it back to the browser
it's all happening in the browser in
real time so the question you might be
asking is how is this a notebook well
it's a notebook because right here we
have this Explorer button in the top
corner and with this one click you're
instantly dropped back into this layer
that's the kind of IDE layer that allows
you to hack on this chunk of code and
edit it for your purposes so you can see
we have something that's it's kind of a
hybrid at this point the UX between
something that looks more like our
studio and something that looks like
Jupiter we have this kind of cell based
interface where the code lives on this
side over here we have a console where
you can see the result of evaluations
and over here we have a report preview
so our mental model for this is a little
bit different than the mental model you
might be used to for something like
Jupiter again because we're focused on
this concept of document production we
want you to want you to have an easy
time producing documents that you can
share with your collaborators but we
want to make this roundtrip really tight
between this idea of you can and this
nice-looking report which gives exactly
the presentation you want to see to a
decision maker but then your data
science collaborators can easily drop
back into the code and for those semi
technical people like oftentimes we have
a lot of product managers at Mozilla who
came from an engineering background if
we can hand them something like this
they can dive into the code and ask that
one incremental question without having
to install all the dependencies and the
like install a full conda environment or
whatever the the similar kind of IT
requirements they can just jump in and
start hacking on this stuff and ask an
additional question so the thing to take
away from this is again that one of the
the main differences here between a
Jupiter style model and the iodide model
is that the the kernel basically lives
or well it really does live in the
browser all of the code evaluation is
happening inside the browser so rather
than having in something like Jupiter or
actually in our studio for that matter
you have what amounts to a browser that
renders the UI but then talks to a
remote kernel so there's some kind of
message passing which can be fast or
slow and can be fast or low latency
depending on whether you're making a
round-trip through the internet or not
all of this lives in the browser and
that has some some nice side effects
also with with respect to sharing of
documents and with respect to IT
requirements so you don't need to make
sure that everybody has the same set up
like the same set of libraries installed
and all the same access to the same data
and dependencies because what you
actually have is just a web page and so
as soon as anyone goes and hits that web
page all the resources they need are
downloaded and so everybody is running
the same code and just to be clear we
love Jupiter we think Jupiter is great
I'm drawing these contrasts but the idea
is not to be throwing shade at Jupiter
in any way we think that we think it's
an awesome tool the idea is that we're
exploring a little bit different part of
the trade-off space and what we're
really trying to do is drawing
inspiration from things like Jupiter in
our studio bring the web to data
scientists so we think these are
complementary tools and they have
complimentary set of trade-offs and
there's one major trade-off that you
might be thinking of so far which is if
it's in the browser are we stuck with
JavaScript so javascript has some some
pretty big pros and cons on the good
side it's actually very fast a lot of
effort has been put into making
javascript interpreters some of the
fastest available for any interpreted
languages on the con side the language
is a lot of legacy rough edges so
backwards compatibility is really
important in the JavaScript ecosystem
that means that there are a lot of old
kind of crufty dark corners of
JavaScript that if you've used it for
any time you'll end up running into
those on the pro side a lot of
programmers end up knowing some
JavaScript but on the con side not that
many data scientists do and that's
primarily because there's not really a
great data science ecosystem in
JavaScript there is on the other hand a
great selection of visuals
and UI tools so trade offs but maybe
we're not stuck with these trade offs
actually so now I'm going to show you
paya dyed which is the scientific Python
stack compiled to run in the browser
soap iodide is the first language plugin
for iodide but it's important to note
that this runs outside of iodide so if
you have the desire to run Python in the
browser for one of your projects you can
take pipe iodide and you can run it
independently for your own projects what
we have in paya died right now is base
Python so the Python interpreter itself
which is just the upstream sea Python
and we have numpy pandas and matplotlib
and all of those are compiled to
webassembly which the technical details
don't really matter but it's kind of
like a like a bit code format for the
web so basically it allows you to take C
code or basically there are a number of
supported language of the languages at
this point you can compile them to run
inside a browser so let me show you what
that looks like and then split this out
so we can look at our report view and
our code console so again when I execute
a markdown cell up here that shows up in
our report view so that'll be something
that's ends up sharing on to our
decision-makers what's going to happen
next as you see right here we have a
pipeline cell and that's indicated by
this little PI up here in the corner
right now the browser hasn't actually
loaded Python so Python can't yet run
inside of the browser what's going to
happen when we execute this cell is
iodides going to recognize that we don't
have the Python interpreter installed
it's going to go out to the network and
fetch the Python interpreter it's then
going to compile it it's going to get it
and then it's going to eval this Python
code so I'm going to do that now and
it's downloading and initializing and
you see it's done so python is actually
small and the jets are actually pretty
fast so it downloaded the the data for
the size of the file for python is i
think it's about like 5 or 10 Meg's and
then the time to JIT is actually very
fast
so now we can eval pipe on code in the
browser and we'll just do a simple list
comprehension you see that shows up here
and now we can we can do some automatic
type conversion so one of the things
that's cool about this is we have pretty
nice and tight interoperability between
Disko
that's now eval din the Python
environment and our regular JavaScript
environment so in this cell I've created
a little Python object now this cell
here is a JavaScript cell we can
actually import that Python object into
JavaScript and now we can apply a
JavaScript map and other JavaScript
functions and that just all works so
that's fine but what when this gets
really cool is that we can actually also
use Python to interact with browser
api's so right here here's another
Python cell and what we're doing is
we're importing iodide which is our own
kind of standard libbed it has a few
convenience functions we're also going
to import document and what that does is
we're pulling a reference into Python to
the document API in the browser and
what's going to happen is in this
function here where we're going to make
some red divs we're going to take these
these Python strings and we're gonna
pass them to there's there's an
automatic type conversion so we're going
to convert them to JavaScript strings
and we're going to pass them to the
document API and that's going to let us
create a div and we're going to
ultimately use this function inside of a
Python list comprehension to create a
few divs and so what we've done is we've
run a little jaw a little Python that's
interfacing with the browser API is and
drawing to the Dom so we can we can do
some cool stuff like that we can also
write here in this case I just attached
created this this this button here and
attached to that button is this callback
function and so this is a callback
function that's written in Python and
when I click this button it will
increment this counter so we're actually
using a Python function as a callback
for again a browser interaction and
that's just like a little simple demo we
can be more elaborate with that so here
I've created a canvas element and we can
actually paint on this canvas and all
the code powering this is is in Python
but we're interacting with browser api's
to allow you to create this rich kind of
experience an interface without having
to touch actually that much JavaScript
for those of us who like me JavaScript
is not their first love so that's all
well and good as far as like cutesy
demos but if you want to do some actual
data science work you're going to need
some data science tooling
so let's take a look at numpy and
matplotlib here
so again numpy is not yet available in
the browser we haven't installed it it's
a bit of a bigger package so we don't
want to we don't want to be downloading
and jetting things that we don't need
and having them sit around in memory so
again what's going to happen is when I
go to import numpy iodides going to
recognize that numpy is not yet
available it's going to go out to the
network pull it down get it and then
evaluate this code so this is going to
take a second longer because numpy is a
little bigger so you see we're loading
here and now it's jittered and done
you'll see on the second evaluation that
most of that most of that latency was
really due to the the JIT actually so
when I run it again you can see it
happens basically like right away and
same thing with nap plot Lib this is
gonna take a second while it fetches
matplotlib but now matplotlib is here
and you'll see on the next evaluation
again it's happening instantaneously so
here's a plot and for for folks who are
used to using that plot lib in the in
the Jupiter context you might not be
aware that actually map lot Lib has this
really nice TK be based viewer that lets
you do things like zoom and pan and kind
of scroll around on a plot so you can
explore matplotlib plots a little more
richly because all of this is happening
again the computation is right here next
to the presentation we can do that stuff
so I can pan on the matplotlib viewer
here or we can zoom in on this part of
the figure if we want we can zoom back
out we can even download a PDF or PNG or
whatever because we're running all of
the kind of basically pretty much the
native matplotlib implementation here
and we can write directly to this chunk
of video memory rather than passing like
PNG is back and forth so we can also
write I'm gonna let me load plotly here
so we just downloaded plotly the
JavaScript version of plotly again this
this nice tight interoperability will
let us import a reference to the plotly
library from
javascript and we have type conversion
again so I can take the these numpy
arrays that we defined above and just
pass them to JavaScript so I'm going to
pass them to plotly here and now here's
a plot lis graph that is displaying
those those numpy arrays and again you
could use something like d3 you could
use whatever your other favorite WebGL
or whatever your favorite data
visualization library is and to beat the
dead horse of the Lorentz attractor
here's the Lorentz attractor again
rendered in matplotlib and once again
because we have the computation app
right here next diwaii
we add the full 3d 3d orbit version of
matplotlib here so that's piyah died and
the next question you might be asking
yourself is is it is it fast enough to
be usable so here's how to read this
plot the vertical red line here is
native performance the bars here are
multiple of native performance so orange
is for firefox blue is for chrome
mozilla has been investing pretty
heavily in getting web assembly to work
really well but we actually expect this
gap to close all of the major browser
vendors are investing about assembly so
right now chrome is 2x ish worse but
that's going to get a lot better the
story here though is is there is a
performance penalty to doing this in the
browser but it's actually it's tractable
for a lot of use cases that you might
encounter and one thing in particular to
notice is that down here at the bottom
of the graph there's an area where we're
actually very very close to native if
you look into the details of these
benchmarks you'll find that those are
those are those are benchmarks that
actually use a lot more numpy so if
you're actually using like vectorized
numpy for a lot of your operations that
actually calls out to c code on the back
end and when you're using c code because
of the way web assembly works that
basically compiles down to two native
machine code through web assembly so
when you're using something that's like
a sea library rather than kind of like
if you're using native Python for big
algorithms that do a ton of stuff in
Python you're
to end up kind of higher up here in the
the wave kind of area but if you're
using numpy and you're really actually
pushing a lot of your computation back
down to the sea layer you can get very
good performance so again there's some
trade-offs here there are some things
that don't work and and probably will
never work
so if part of your workflow that is
critical is actually writing to the file
system because we're in the browser that
is not going to work straight away the
browser won't let you for very good
reasons won't let a web page write
arbitrarily to somebody's file system
same thing with rod network sockets
there are good security reasons why
that's not allowed and the browser
doesn't support true subprocesses new
stuffs being added to the webassembly
spec all the time though and so some of
those sub process oriented workflows
should hopefully be satisfied someday
soon by threads and co-routines and
where we're going in the future is to
try to get Sipe I like the rest of Sai
PI working here so again we have numpy
pandas and matplotlib at the moment the
next thing up is Sai pi and that will
unlock Sai kit image and scikit-learn
the blocker on this is Fortran and if we
can talk about some more in the QA if
people are interested but Fortran
doesn't it's it's a legacy language and
it doesn't have great modern compiler
support so that's blocking getting Sai
high running for now we have we have
some ideas about how to solve that and
one of the cool things about getting
Fortran working is that once we have
Fortran working R is actually blocked by
Fortran so then we can get our running
in the web also and in the same way that
you've seen this this story about this
nice interoperability between passing
data structures back and forth between
Python and kind of Java scripts to
enable these workflows where you can use
Python for some of your processing and
then maybe JavaScript for your data vis
you can imagine a workflow where you'll
use Python for some your data munging
maybe run your favorite statistical
model and R and then pass that data
seamlessly back into into JavaScript to
do your data visualization and at the
end of the day you have rather than
serializing and deserializing data
between a bunch of places and having a
bundle of files that you need to share
to your collaborators you have this one
document that has a mix of Python
and JavaScript sells and so the workflow
is much more kind of seamless and much
more tidy and organized we think in the
future that the key glue that's gonna
tie these runtimes together is Apache
arrow so we're working with we're
working on trying to get arrow running
in the browser and we well we actually
have arrow running the browser we're
working on getting a nice front-end that
will make it appealing to work within
JavaScript we're also working on some
stuff around rust because rust is
another language that targets the
browser well and I don't know if there
are many talks about arrow here this
week but last week at PI data in NYC I
guess some people from the pandas team
we're talking about how they're starting
to move to arrow as their back-end for
for data processing and it seems like
this is the direction that a lot of data
processing is going so we're we're eager
to jump in with that we're also working
with Conda Forge to add web assembly as
a compiled target for conda's build
infrastructure so right now obviously
you can use Conda to package binaries
for the different kind of operating
system platforms what this is going to
mean is that without having to rewrite
your entire set of build scripts you
just have this other back-end and your
stuff will run on the web which is kind
of amazing and we we actually one of our
people sprinted with some people from
Conda last week and I think we think we
cleared out some of the big hurdles
there and we see a good path forward for
that last thing I'll mention is the
iodide server and I'm just going to talk
about this very briefly again we're
trying to tighten this loop between
these these phases of this workflow
because a lot of this stuff lives in the
web and because we we actually have a
pretty simple document format on the
back it actually there's a little
simpler actually than the the Jupiter
notebook the I PI I PI NB format and so
getting to a Google Docs like experience
actually we think is something that
we're going to be able to do pretty
quickly and what we're really working on
in terms of this idea of having this
optional server is it'll be a place for
sharing these reports for doing
commenting on the code or
on the report side of the thing of the
the document for doing collaborative
editing for doing forking merging style
workflows and then for doing archived
exports where you can take kind of a
snapshot of what was the iodide codebase
thought was involved in this particular
project at this particular point in time
what were all the resources you pulled
from the network download all of those
and bundle them into like a zip file and
then you'll have a reproducible archive
that will run exactly the same forever
the other thing that this server is
going to do for us is act as a
go-between for for accessing data
sources so again this all runs in the
browser and what that means is kind of a
default way of getting data into your
workspace is to do an HTTP GET request
and what that's gonna do is pull down
data from like a public site on the web
of course if you don't want your data to
be public if it's behind off of some
sort what the server can do is act as a
go-between to provide authorization or
to be like an intermediary between
something like PI spark so that's that's
the other part of what the server is
gonna do and so that's it for this this
quick overview of this this project
we're very much alpha this is very much
an experiment still and we would
definitely love the help of more people
in this community to think about what
this could be and to help us build it so
if you're at all interested hit us up
we're here on github
you can take a look at our code and you
can join us shout out to the rest of the
folks on the team I wanna yeah I'll
mention Mike drove boom in particular I
did pretty much everything for the the
Piatt died part of this project so shout
out to him and then yeah if you want to
contact me I'm be colouring at Mozilla
and again find us on github so thanks we
can go to questions
[Applause]
so what actually is happening on the no
no we didn't what's actually happening
is that the tool that we're using to do
the compilation is this tool called M
scripting and it actually does some
pretty sophisticated automatic object
translation and so that stuff is all for
free so it just gives you kind of
straightaway access to the exact names
of the the Dom API as they existed so
yeah so it's it's that it's we didn't
add any extra there's no additional
human written code in there it's all
freebie just based on how I'm scripting
works totally yeah so there are there
are a lot of kind of similar projects
that are doing similar things like
observable is a tool that is kind of in
a similar run javascript in the in your
browser space and and of course there
are things even like kind of like code
pen and jsfiddle so observable is is
really cool and really interesting and
our emphasis again is really on this
idea of communication so observable is
like a really cool tool for
experimenting with algorithms and
exploring javascript what we're trying
to do is really open up the space for
data scientists to to get into the web a
little more easily to tell the stories
that they might want to be able to tell
but that the tooling isn't really there
like this point in the in the world of
web development to really get into it
you need to like as you were talking
about you alluded to in your talk you
have to start you need to know web pack
and you need to like know NPM and and
there's a pretty high barrier to entry
to start writing JavaScript code and
getting it out there so we're just
trying to ease that workflow with this
kind of iterative interactive similar
again to
things like Jupiter lab in our studio
yeah so I guess I'll just show really
quickly so alright so here's here's our
actually that's a good this one so
here's our Lorenz attractor notebook for
example and if we just view source on
this page what you'll see is that this
is actually a pretty simple HTML
document and what we have in here this
little bigger is um we have this this
format that we're calling J SMD so it's
like JavaScript markdown kind of
inspired by our markdown or like MATLAB
cell node and I think I think Jupiter no
house Jew Patek store something like
that which is a mode that's like this
and so what we have is actually a really
simple text-based format here so it's
that's actually something that we've
encountered and that we're trying to be
mindful of is is keeping things human
readable difficult easy to use in like a
regular text editor rather than using a
richard json format again there are
trade-offs in that so one of the things
that we don't do that that jupiter does
an awesome job at is when you save a
jupiter notebook it kind of bundles all
of the artifacts so that you have this
thing that has all of the images and
everything else that you would want to
just you could just hand that to
somebody and they can put it in and be
viewer and see what that looks like for
this you actually have to run the code
that's an intentional trade-off though
because what we're trying to do is
enable these live interactive
visualization style stories so does that
answer that question great
anyone else all right looks like not
well thank you all for coming
[Applause]